احمد ماذا عن هذا السحب للواء جولاني من
غزه رغم ان الجيش يقول انه مرحلي لاعاده
تنظيم صفوفه ماذا عن هذه الخطوه وردود
الفعل حولها حتى
الان عبد القادر الحديث هنا عن سحب كتيبه
من هذا اللواء وهي الكتيبه رقم 13 والتي
تعرضت لخسائر فادحه على
يد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه حركه حماس وغيرها من الفصائل
42 شخصا او جنديا اسرائيليا ينتمون الى
هذه الكتيبه قد قتلوا في معارك داخل قطاع
غزه ناهيك عن عشرات وعشرات من الجرحى اي
ان قتلى هذه الكتيبه هم 42 من 71 قتل
اللواء اي ان هذه الكتيبه تعرضت هي بدورها
لاكبر خسائر ضمن الويه و ضمن عفوا كتائب
وفرق هذا اللواء بما في ذلك قائد هذه
الكتيبه وعدد من الضباط المرافقين له
الاسبوع الماضي عندما قتلوا في حي
الشجاعيه باستهداف المبنى الذين كانوا
يقطون يقطنون ه هذا هذه هذه هذا السحب عبد
القادر هو حسب الجيش الاسرائيلي لاعاده
تنظيم واعاده تنشيط هذه الكتيبه لتكون
جاهزه مره اخرى وتعويضها عن ما تعرضت له
من خسائر في هذا القطاع لكنه يعطي رساله
واضحه هنا في الشارع الاسرائيلي بان هذه
الحرب الشرسه التي تقودها اسرائيل منذ
اكثر من 76 يوما في قطاع غزه لا تزال لم
تحقق اييا من الاهداف المعلنه وهو القضاء
على حركه حماس وتفكيك بنيتها التحتيه
وحرمانها او او من منعها من اطلاق صواريخ
على اسرائيل اليوم او بالامس صباحا اطلقت
الصواريخ على عده مدن اسرائيليه بما في
ذلك مدينه تل ابيب وضواحيها وصولا الى
هرسل هذا يعطي مؤشر هنا للشارع الاسرائيلي
من العمل العمليه العسكريه التي يقول
المسؤول الاسرائيليون بانها عمليه قاسيه
جدا
وعمليه معقده للغايه لا تزال عوضا عن
تدمير جزء كبير من البنيه التحتيه في قطاع
غزه وقتل الالاف والالاف من المدنيين الا
انها لم تتمكن حتى اللحظه من الحد من قدره
حركه الم حركه حماس وفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه من توجيه ضربات قاسيه لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وايضا ضربات صاروخيه
على الم الاسرائيليه وهذا سيشكل ضغطا
كبيرا على صناع القرار هنا في اسرائيل
خصوصا في
ظل تهافت او
او تهافت الحديث عن المحاولات اسرائيليه
للوصول الى صفقه تبادل الاسرى مع حركه
حماس وان هذا الحديث الان بات يواجه صعوبه
او واجه طريقا مسدودا وذلك نتيجه لرفض
حركه حماس الدخول في هذا التفاوض حتى وقف
اسرائيل لعملياته العسكريه وهو امر اذا
اذا قامت به اسرائيل فانها ستقوم به
والمؤشرات تقول بانها لم تحقق ايا من
اهدافها ما يجعل هذا القرار صعبا للغايه
على صناع القرار في اسرائيل هناك انباء
نقلا عن وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه من ان مجلس
الحرب يجتمع حاليا لبحث عده امور متعلقه
بالحرب على غزه بما في ذلك خسائر الجيش
الاسرائيلي وايضا احتماليه
و بحث امكانيه تغيير الرؤيه الاسرائيليه
او العرض الاسرائيلي لصفقه تبادل اسرى
لتكون اكثر مقبوله لحركه حماس وفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه عبد القادر